all right so this is how you get into a  six-step because the last thing you want  to do it there's some terrible Roger  Rabbit or whatnot and then fumble your  way down to the ground to get into the  six-step it ruins the whole effect so  this may cut off my head which doesn't  matter but these are a few options for  getting into it and hopefully the visual  will be enough because I feel the music  is important  this is freestylers very good for a  practicing brightening to see side notes  this is a slow part if you're waiting  for appropriate music then you can go  and they slow circly suit I mean  and getting out number two morning when  you get out of it go on your left knee  so what I just did here that's here drop  down right here and then went into it  you get up other options is you will  take through  other options is what you might call  flare start number one  not wise just like straight  that's it for now that was all done  using mostly what I just showed you have  fun